l'évolution par les yeux de valérie à
dos santos est fini de claude
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat hier les sénateurs ont adopté à
l'unanimité la proposition de loi de la
sénatrice catherine morin desailly qui
autorise la restitution des têtes
maories à la nouvelle zélande
le nouveau ministre de la culture
frédéric mitterrand dans sa première
intervention devant la haute assemblée a
apporté son soutien à cette proposition
de loi
en octobre 2007 la ville de rouen avait
décidé de rendre les têtes maories
qu'elle conservait dans son musée depuis
cette décision avait été annulée par le
tribunal administratif saisi par
christine albanel la ministre de la
culture de l'époque celle ci craignaient
que cette situation ne fasse
jurisprudence et que la france ne soit
obligé de rendre tous les restes du vin
qu'elle possède dans ses musées c'est
donc l'adoption de cette proposition de
loi que je vous propose de voir ce matin
bonne séance à tous sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour appelle maintenant la
discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à autoriser la restitution par la
france dans la france des têtes maories
propositions présentées par madame
catherine morin desailly et plusieurs de
ses collègues dans la discussion
générale la parole et à madame catherine
morin desailly auteur de la proposition
de loi vous parole chers collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur là le rapporteur du
cher collègue
permettez moi monsieur le ministre de
profiter de cette occasion en préambule
pour vous féliciter de votre nomination
vous souhaitez également la bienvenue au
sénat autre palais italiens en somme
vous qui accueillait si chaleureusement
il ya quelques semaines à peine une
délégation du groupe d'amitié france
italie de notre assemblée donc plusieurs
membres aujourd'hui présent dans son
débat y siègent membre de la commission
des affaires culturelles l'expérience
nous prouve malheureusement combien il
faut de temps afin que nous considérions
comme nos semblables
les hommes qui diffère de nous par leur
aspect extérieur et par leurs coutumes
c'est ainsi que s'exprime et charles
darwin en 1871 et malheureusement ce
constat semble aujourd'hui toujours
pertinent comme le prouvent histoire de
la restitution de la tête maorie de la
ville d'un plan la proposition de loi
assez inhabituel mais co signée par une
soixantaine de mes collègues que j'ai
souhaité vous soumettre vise à permettre
la restitution à leur pays d'origine de
toutes les têtes maories qui sont
actuellement détenus dans les
collections des musées français monde du
groupe d'amitié france nouvelle zélande
de notre haute assemblée je me suis en
effet passionné pour l'histoire de ces
têtes
lorsqu'elle joue dans la culture du
maire de rouen pierre albertini je
travaillais alors à la réouverture du
muséum d'histoire naturelle le deuxième
plus important en terme de richesse et
de diversité des collections après celui
de faerie qui avait été fermée pour des
raisons de sécurité pendant une bonne
dizaine d'années avec la nouvelle équipe
scientifique
recruté pour mettre en oeuvre le nouveau
projet alors défini pour le muséum
nous avons en effet répondu à la demande
de la nouvelle zélande de lui restituer
une tête humaine tatouées et momifiées
conservées depuis 1875 dongou dépôt
comme on voudra d'un certain monsieur
drouet pour ne sais quel motif
elle dormait là caché depuis le 19e
siècle dans les réserves et collection
non inventorié du muséum
si cette proposition de loi vise à
répondre aux difficultés juridiques
rencontré par la ville de rouen
lorsqu'elle a décidé en octobre 2007 de
remettre aux autorités aux autorités néo
zélandaises
après des échanges et une réflexion
notamment avec l'équipe scientifique du
muséum sept têtes maories elle doit
permettre surtout si elle adopte est de
mettre la france au diapason de très
nombreux autres pays en resituant
finalement et logiquement l'ensemble des
têtes maories évalué à ce jour entre 15
et 20 conservés dans nos musées sept à
huit au quai branly une au musée de la
charité une au musée des beaux arts de
dunkerque 4 dans des musées hommes dont
bien sûr celui d'euros mais aussi à lyon
lille nantes une au muséum de la
rochelle dépôt des structures de la
marine de rochefort
enfin deux à l'université de montpellier
un petit retour en arrière et l'
essentiel pour comprendre de cette
affaire tous les maoris d'euros guerrier
et chefs de tribus et est tatoué selon
des motifs rappelant leur tribu selon
leurs traditions en effet la tête et
considérer comme la partie sacrée du
corps et le tatouage comme une véritable
signature sociale et religieuse
le peuple maori avait ainsi coutume de
conserver les têtes tatouées des
guerriers morts au combat et de les
exposer dans un endroit consacré à leur
mémoire où chacun pouvait les vénérer
jusqu'au moment où estimé que l'âme du
défunt était parti les têtes étaient
alors inhumé près du village au xviiie
siècle lors de la colonisation de la
nouvelle zélande les européens se
fascine pour les têtes tatouées qu'ils
qualifient d' objet de curiosité de
collection les musées et les
collectionneurs privés lance de
véritables chasseurs de tête à la
recherche des plus beaux spécimens
s'ensuit un véritable commerce barbare
pour répondre à la demande on se met à
tatouer les esclaves dont on tranche la
tête
ce n'est qu'en 1831 que le gouvernement
britannique vote une loi interdisant le
marché des têtes naturalisé entre la
nouvelle-zélande et l'australie
l'amiral cécile dont la flotte était
implanté dans le pacifique a dénoncé
trafic qui avait abouti à une véritable
marchandisation du corps humain dans un
rapport adressé alors au ministre de la
marine en 1840 qu'il écrive à il
écrivait pardon on a vu les têtes néo
zélandaise devenir un objet lucrative
d'exportation tous les moyens ont été
bons pour s'en procurer et des guerres
ont été suscités entre les tribus pour
faire baisser le prix de cette
marchandise recherché par les
naturalistes
on a vu des individus précédé chefs et
leur assurer des présents pour se faire
livrer la tête remarquablement tatoué de
quelques esclaves
le regard que portent les néo zélandais
aujourd'hui sur cette tête est bien
différent du nôtre
pour eux ce sont des les restes de leurs
ancêtres des éléments du corps humain
d'où leur demande de restitution
alors que les occidentaux les considère
plutôt comme des objets d'art enlevé à
des sauvages
les hausses de leurs pairs vous leur
enlever leur histoire leur loi jusqu
alors dieu vous ravissent et à ses
hommes parmi les générations futures
la preuve de leur existence comme celle
de leur nez en cette citation de
châteaubriant extraites des mémoires
d'autres tombes exprime combien pour se
construire pour se forger une identité
les peuples ont besoin de leurs ancêtres
comme l'a écrit jean-yves marin
directeur du musée de normandie dans un
article récemment publié un peuple sans
histoire ne peut se renouveler et
condamné à disparaître
d'ailleurs que dirions nous si les têtes
de nos propres ancêtres de nos arrières
arrières grands parents étaient remisés
dans les réserves de musées
néo-zélandais ou dans tout autre pays et
qu'on refuse et nous les restituer à la
demande de la nouvelle zélande ces têtes
ont d'ailleurs été retirée des
expositions publiques depuis environ 20
ans elle se trouve aujourd'hui dans les
réserves de musées occidentaux parfois
conservé dans des conditions laissant à
désirer
c'est d'ailleurs vrai de nombreux
résolument générale comme l'a établi une
enquête réalisée par leurs cadeaux
élaine michaud pour le centre de
recherche et de restauration des musées
de france
depuis les autorités néo zélandaises et
australiennes ont lancé une campagne de
revendications de ces têtes afin de
pouvoir les inhumer dans le respect des
traditions eric unis
de ce peuple autochtone comptant
aujourd'hui six cent mille personnes
en effet le but de ces rapatriements
n'est pas un transfert d'une étagère de
musée à une autre en l'occurrence celui
de tes papa à wellington mais de
retourner ces têtes à leur communauté
d'origine
la restitution d'un lieu à de véritables
cérémonie ainsi que mon leur apporter
des témoignages datant pour certains d'à
peine quelques jours cérémonie qui sont
lancés dès le pays de départ des restes
humains
ainsi les maoris se sont déplacés armand
pour venir honorer la tête de leurs
ancêtres et lui rendent hommage
la manifestation que nous avions
organisée alors à l'hôtel de ville fut
de l'avis de tous de tous les
participants extrêmement émouvante
la question qui se pose alors est de
savoir si juridiquement ces têtes sont
les objets d'art de collection ou des
restes humains en effet de cette
question relative à leur statut
juridique dépendant régimes différents
un objet patrimonial obéit en droit
français aux principes digne à l'éviter
ce qui interdit toute restitution en
dehors d'une procédure préalable des
classements ce régime s'applique aux
pièces détenues dans les collections
publiques au contraire un reste humain
en application de l'article 16 1 du code
civil ne peut faire l'objet d'un droit
patrimonial
dès lors il n'entre pas dans la
catégorie des biens culturels éléments
du corps humain indéniablement c'est
être tatoués modifié issus d'un trafic
barba durant la période de colonisation
ne peuvent se voir appliquer ce principe
d'inaliénabilité pour nous aurons la
tête maorie
lenny propriété l'état ni celle du
muséum elle ne figurait d'ailleurs dans
aucun inventaire ce qui rendait le
déclassement impossible en décidant par
un vote à l'unanimité en conseil
municipal de remettent à la nouvelle
zélande s'était tu nous avons voulu nous
à frire dans une démarche éthique
faisant du muséum de la ville un muséum
durable et responsable en ce début de
21e siècle
un acte symbolique exprimant le respect
des peuples et de leurs croyances de toi
ne doit-on pas en effet considéré que
c'était deux sont parties intégrantes
nom de la nation mais du patrimoine de
l'humanité telle que défendue par l'unef
comme un acquis irréductibles de notre
diversité
cependant sur intervention de l'état la
délibération du conseil municipal a été
annulée par le juge administratif au
motif que la procédure de déclassement
préalable prévue par le code du
patrimoine n'avaient pas été mises en
oeuvre et que l'article 16 1 du code
civil sur lequel nous étions fondés
était inapplicable en l'espèce je doute
fort au passage que si la commission
veut étendre pour le déclassement alors
exclusivement composée de conservateurs
s'ils avaient été réunies lui donnait
alors son accord cet événement a donné
lieu par la suite en février 2008 un
colloque international au musée du quai
branly portant sur la conservation
l'exposition et la restitution des aides
des restes humains colloque au cours
duquel je suis d'ailleurs intervenu pour
témoigner de l'histoire de la tête
maorie dormant
ce jour là le commissaire du
gouvernement présent m'a signalé que la
cour d'appel de douai avait statué dans
le sens de la nonne applicabilité martic
16,1 mais aurait pu finalement tout
aussi bien faire le contraire tant le
statut juridique des restes humains
demeurent encore floues aujourd'hui
objet de collection l'application de la
loi du 4 janvier 2002 relative aux
musées de france avec procédure de
déclassement ou restes humains et
application de l'article 16 du code
civil qui résulte de la loi du 29
juillet 1994 sur la bioéthique que le
gouvernement souhaitait d'ailleurs
appliqué dans le cas de la vénus
hottentote ce débat juridique suscitée
par la décision de la ville de rouen
s'est en effet posé dans les données
termes quasi identiques à ceux soulevés
lors de la vénus dans la restitution par
la france à l'afrique du sud de la
dépouille mortelle pardonnez-moi de
sarah bartman conservés dans les
collections du musée de l'homme notre
collègue nicolas bour ici présents
étaient alors intervenus en faisant
voter une loi permettant de sortir la
vénus hottentote des collections
publiques
à l'époque on s'est même interrogé sur
l'utilité d'une loi le gouvernement
considérait alors que le cas de la vénus
hottentote relevé de l'application de
l'article 16 1 du code civil
application contester aujourd'hui pour
les têtes maories
mais l'actualité nous rattrape
maintenant avec l'annulation de
l'exposition contesté à un bandit à
coups d'appel de paris celle ci s'est
précisément appuyé sur l'article 16 1 1
du code civil
introduit en décembre 2008 et dont les
dispositions sont dans public qui
dispose que le respect dû au corps
humain ne cesse pas avec la mort que les
restes des personnes décédées doivent
être traités avec respect dignité et
décence
la cour rappelle pour fonder sa décision
que la protection due au corps humain
vivant et dépouille mortelle prévue par
le législateur a un caractère inviolable
et digne de respect absolu
conformément un principe fondamental de
toute société humaine
cette décision fortement médiatisée a
permis peut-être de mieux prendre
conscience des problèmes éthiques posés
par l'exposition pour ne pas dire
l'exhibition des corps humain la
question donc de l'applicabilité de
l'article 16-1 demeure il apparaît que
les restes humains occupe une position
dont charnière pour le plan juridique et
que la loi de bioéthique de 1994 protège
davantage le liban vis-à-vis notamment
du trafic d'organes et des risques en
matière d'étude génétique
c'est en tout cas ce que laisse entendre
l'interprétation du juge dans l'espèce
faut-il pour autant lui laissait
l'avenir la charge de décider au nom au
cas par cas de l'application des
dispositions
là se trouve une vraie question c'est le
ministre mes chers collègues à laquelle
au delà de cette proposition de loi
il conviendra de répondre considérons
l'incertitude dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons j'ai choisit donc de déposer
cette proposition de loi
si nous l'adoptons aujourd'hui ce que
j'espère vivement elle permettra de
régler le cas des têtes maories et je
suis consciente que la loi n'est
peut-être pas l'outil le plus approprié
pour régler la question j'aurais préféré
sans doute ne pas y avoir recours
mais elle est la seule solution face à
l'impasse dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons et à l'imbroglio juridique en
résultant j'ai constaté en effet que si
la loi de 2002 invite les responsables
des musées à définir des critères pour
encadrer d'éventuels déclassement de
décoller
son public dans le cadre d'une procédure
spécifique et après avis conforme de la
commission nationale scientifique elle
n'a pu à ce jour est pleinement mis en
oeuvre ces critères qui permettait
justement de préciser les conditions
dans lesquelles ce principe d'année les
habilités pouvait ne pas s'impliquer
donc toujours pas été définis plus de
sept ans après son adoption par ailleurs
en vertu de la loi de 2002 les bien
incorporés dans les collections
publiques pardon et par l'aig
et c'est le cas de la teste maori de
rome et de nombreuses autres têtes
enfance ne peuvent faire l'objet d'aucun
des classements contrairement à ce qui
était soutenu conscience donc de
l'importance et la difficulté de la
question qui ne saurait être un prétexte
pour ouvrir la boîte de pandore comme on
l'a trop souvent entendu dire j'ai
souhaité m'inspirer pour cadrer la
présente proposition de loi de quatre
critères retenus à leur part la ville
d'oran pour motiver sa décision de
restitution le premier est que le pays
d'origine d'un peuple contemporain et
formulé la demande de restitution
le second est que ce restes humains ne
fassent pas l'objet de recherches
scientifiques
le troisième est qu'ils ne soient pas
destinés à être exposés ni conservées
dans les réserves dans des réserves dans
le pays d'origine mais qu'il soit inhumé
enfin le dernier critère est que le
reste soit issue d'actes de barbarie
ayant entraîné la mort ou alors de
pratiques attentatoires à la dignité
humaine on sait en effet que toutes ces
têtes ne sont pas forcément des têtes
d'esclaves mais aussi des têtes de chefs
guerriers
il ne reste pas moins qu'elles ont été
volées comme trophée à une époque où les
musées occidentaux étaient largement
prédateurs je voudrais attirer votre
attention par ailleurs sur le fait que
la france a ratifié la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones de septembre 2007 qui dans
les articles 11 et 12 en juin les états
accorder réparation aux peuples
autochtones et dispose que les états
veille à permettre l'accès aux objets de
culte et aux restes humains en leur
possession et oullins rapatriement par
le biais de mécanismes juste transparent
et efficace
mise au point en concertation avec les
peuples autochtones concernées le geste
de rands aujourd'hui les têtes maories
s'inscrit pleinement dans le cadre de
cette déclaration
par ailleurs
le code de déontologie de l'icom qui est
l'aboutissement de six années de
révision qui a été formellement
approuvées lors de la 21e assemblée
générale à séoul en octobre 2004 a
largement abordé cette question qui est
encore pudiquement appelée matériels
culturels sensible pour autant monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaite vivement que cette proposition
de loi contribue comme l'avait alors
voulu mes collègues nicolas bour et
philippe richert tu lors de la
proposition de restitution de la vénus
hottentote à l'afrique du sud à une
réflexion plus globale sur la
conservation des restes humains dans les
musées contrairement à d'autres pays
voisins la france accuse il faut bien le
reconnaître un grand retard sur ces
questions faussement préparation
anatomique momie grlic diverses la
variété la quantité des restes humains
dans les musées autres laboratoires sont
grandes
la spécificité ses collections soulève
aujourd'hui
quoi qu'on en pense de nombreuses
questions éthiques quant à laure
patrimonialisation nos collègues
flipnote pas et philippe richert ont
d'ailleurs rendu un rapport en juillet
2003 sur les collections du musée dans
lesquels il évoquait déjà la question
des réserves de leur gestion mais aussi
des restes humains détenus dans les
collections notamment au musée de
l'homme au sujet duquel il avait
constaté un et allan poe cirage
préoccupants sont ce travail préalable
indispensable
nous serons toujours contraint de
procéder au coup par coup ce qui n'est
guère satisfaisant
cette affaire a de nouveau mis en
lumière les dysfonctionnements
administratifs le problème de la gestion
des collections muséales et les
contradictions de la législation
française qui méritent des clarisses
d'être clarifier une fois pour toutes
jacques rigaud auxquels notre précédente
ministre de la culture avait confié une
mission à noter lui-même je cite
l'inertie manifeste de l'institution
muséale
les responsables de musées ou trop
longtemps esquivé ce débat faisant même
preuve d'un certain malaise sur un sujet
dont ils ne savent comment s'emparer
cette affaire a révélé également un
certain conservatisme une certaine
logique dans laquelle parfois nous
sommes enfoncés notre regard
d'occidental qui a parfois du mal à
accepter notre vision du monde le
rapporteur
et je partage pleinement ses
préconisations à d'ailleurs en chie la
proposition de loi de plusieurs articles
qui visent notamment élargir la
composition de la commission de
déclassement afin qu'elles comportent
delà des professionnels de la
conservation des biens des personnes
qualifiées
car si la valeur scientifique des restes
humains se présente comme une évidence
pour les conservateurs on ne peut mettre
de côté la valeur symbolique et même
sacré qu'il incarne pour les communautés
où les peuples auxquels ils peuvent être
attachés aussi faut-il réfléchir au sens
que l'on donne aux collections la
science ne pouvant se passer d'une
réflexion éthique au sens premier du
terme ce que ce qui n'a rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec la religion
c'est un véritable chantier qu'il nous
faut ouvrir sans tabou bien entendu il
ne s'agit ici nullement de limiter ou de
remettre en cause le principe
d'inaliénabilité des collections
publiques auquel je suis personnellement
extrêmement attachés c'est d'ailleurs
l'intérêt des critères que j'évoquais
précédemment mais aussi du régime
spécifique prévue par la loi de 2002 que
notre collègue rapporteur propose de
renforcer
à cette occasion les tno anthropologue
spécialiste de l'océanic que nous avons
auditionné maurice godelier partage
cette position
considérant que si les restes humains ne
sont pas des objets de collection comme
les autres ils doivent être restitués
ces rapatriements doivent être pour
autant encadré afin de garder trace de
ces pièces dans les musées français par
numérisation par exemple la ville de van
a d'ores et déjà réfléchi à la façon
dont l'histoire de cette tête pourrait
être racontée car il ne s'agit pas de
cacher cet épisode de l'histoire du midi
homme nie avoir un trou dans sa mémoire
mais au contraire de le valoriser
ainsi le directeur sébastien maintien
engager un travail de numérisation de la
tête et tout une démarche pédagogique à
destination des visiteurs
quel que soit le moyen par lequel nous
procédons pour restituer les têtes
maories
je suis persuadé que tous ici sur les
bancs de cette musique partageons cet
objectif légitime de restituer à leurs
peuples d'origine les têtes parties du
corps humain probablement la plus
caractéristique de ce qu'est la nature
humaine
en tout cas partie la plus sacrée pour
les maoris afin d'être dignement inhumé
la grande majorité d'ailleurs des
personnes que nous avons rencontrées
défendent également cette position et
ont reconnu le bien fondé de cet acte à
l'époque valérie pécresse notre ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche avait même émis un avis
favorable à cette démarche
le paléoanthropologue pascal picq
avaient d'ailleurs dès le début pris la
tête d'un comité de soutien alors mis en
place rejoints par plusieurs
personnalités
la culture ne peut se passer la
transparence de la vérité elle doit
répondre à une éthique irréprochable
on ne peut sous son couvert porter
atteinte aux droits des peuples et la
france pays des droits de l'homme se
doit d'être exemplaire
de nombreux pays ont déjà remis des
têtes des musées américains européens
ont répondu favorablement aux demandes
de restitution la suisse l'angleterre le
danemark les pays-bas d'allemagne mais
aussi l'argentine l'australie au total
près de 322 restes humains maoris
sur les 500 et 6 mai ont déjà été
transférés à la nouvelle zélande la
france est aujourd'hui exception dans ce
mouvement général en raison de la
question du statut juridique que
j'évoquais finalement davantage une
question de forme que de fond notre pays
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ne peut rester en retrait sur ce sujet
par rapport à ses voisins notamment
européens
un tel geste favoris s'en doutera
travail de mémoire de sa cicatrisation
permet de tourner une page de l'histoire
française peu glorieuse et d'entamer de
nouvelles relations avec la nouvelle
zélande
au delà des considérations juridiques
c'est finalement l'impératif impératif
éthique qui doit prévaloir me
semble-t-il
et cette restitution ou plutôt cette
renonciation à détenir dans nos
collections ces têtes constituera en
outre un nouveau départ dans nos
relations avec les pays lointains dans
le cadre d'un dialogue interculturel
renouveler car ils ne seraient s'agit en
effet de rendre pour rendent le dialogue
et l'harmonie entre les peuples implique
d'entrer en contact avec la civilisation
de l'autre avec un grand tas et
réciproquement
aussi face à ce profond désir de
restitution manifestée par la
nouvelle-zélande pays démocratique qui
travaille précisément aujourd'hui à
l'intégration de toutes ces communautés
la france doit apporter une réponse
positive
en conclusion je voudrais vous remercier
mes chers collègues
qu'ils avaient co signé cette
proposition de loi est accompagné la
démarche je voudrais remercier notre
président la commission les affaires
culturelles qui m'avait apporté son
soutien et bien sûr notre rapporteur
philippe richert qui a réalisé un très
gros travail un travail approfondi sur
la question et avec lequel j'ai chance
sur ce sujet si sensible depuis des mois
je vous remercie tous de votre attention
sur un sujet qui vous l'aurez compris me
tiens tout particulièrement à coeur je
vous remercie chers collègues là par
l'état monsieur philippe richert
rapporteur de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication
c'est ainsi la nouvelle dénomination
prévu par la résolution du 2 juin le
rapporteur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous venons
d'entendre
l'auteur de la proposition de loi
catherine morin dessailly vous aurez
compris toute l'énergie la passion
qu'elle met dans la défense des idées
qui qu'elle porte dans le cadre de cette
proposition de loi pour permettre la
restitution des têtes maories à la
nouvelle zélande et vous le savez tous
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
sénat à l'occasion de débattre d'un
sujet de cette nature puisque certains
s'en souviennent certainement nous avons
eu l'occasion en 2002 de débattre d'une
proposition de loi déposée alors par le
président nicolas bour une proposition
de loi qui tendait à rendre à l'afrique
du sud la dépouille mortelle de saartjie
baartman qu'on appelle vénus hottentote
cette femme qui avait connu un triste
sort et qui était devenue un symbole d
humiliation subie par son peuple son
corps s'étant retrouvé exhibé puis
conservés dans les réserves du muséum
national d'histoire naturelle alors
rapporteur de ce texte au sénat
c'est est d'avis que n'avait pas de
raison de faire une proposition de loi
j'avoue que j'étais d'abord opposé au
principe même de cette proposition de
l'opi quand j'ai vu les tergiversations
parfois même les barrages de
l'administration je me rappelle lorsque
nous visitions le musée de l'homme
bah tel conservateur qui m'expliquait
qu'il n'y avait plus de reste puisqu'il
avait été perdue cela était bien ce qui
avait été dit au rapporteur de la
commission des affaires culturelles qui
s'était rendu au muséum et on lui
expliquait qu'en fait il y avait plus
lieu de faire de propositions grave
puisque les parties molles comme on le
disait avait été perdu et bien on s'est
rendu compte que il ya parfois un peu de
lourdeur et que face à ces atermoiements
je crois qu'il est bon que nous
puissions clarifié par des lois
raison pour laquelle la proposition de
loi de catherine morin dessailly a été
signé par beaucoup de ses collègues et
en particulier par nicolas goût qui
récidivent en quelque sorte et qui
apporte son soutient la démarche qu'elle
a initiés c'est le cas des têtes maories
qui nous attire aujourd'hui suscite on
peut le dire ici dans cette assemblée
une large adhésion puisqu'à ce jour
pratiquement 60 sénateurs issus des
différents groupes politiques ont co
signé ce texte après l'intervention de
l'auteur de la proposition de loi vous
comprendrez que je pourrais me permettre
d'être plus bref sur les éléments de
contexte pour m'attacher vous présenter
les conclusions de la commission et les
dispositions que nous avons souhaité
introduire dans le texte afin d'en
renforcer la portée
en effet au delà de son objet
ponctuelles cette proposition de loi
soulève des questions importantes par
leur portée culturelle éthique et moral
elle contribue à relancer un débat
important sur des sujets que nous avions
déjà abordé dans cet hémicycle sept ans
plus tôt or contrairement à la volonté
alors exprimé par le législateur à la
fois au moment des lois sur les musées
de france et sur la vénus hottentote
les choses n'ont pas avancé comme nous
l'aurions souhaité cette proposition de
loi on est le révélateur
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité que son
examen nous offre une opportunité pour
réactiver ce dossier pour réutiliser ce
débat en vue de faire avancer une
réflexion selon nous indispensable
préalable
je vous rappelle que les têtes humaines
bonifié tatoué dont il est question dans
ce texte sont une tradition du peuple
maori
autochtones de nouvelle zélande avec
l'arrivée des colons européens c'est
être considérées comme des objets de
collection ont suscité un engouement
macabre et fait l'objet d'un trafic
sordide jusqu'au milieu du xixème siècle
si bien que certains esclaves ou la tête
tatouée tout à l'heure catherine le
rappelait puis ont ensuite été décapité
pour satisfaire à la demande ainsi que
certaines de ces têtes se sont retrouvés
dispersées dans les musées d'europe ou
d'amérique mais aussi dans des
collections privées
d'après des informations qui nous ont
été transmises si mu et celui du quai
branly et cinq musées territoriaux ont
une ou plusieurs de ces têtes soit au
total une douzaine dans leurs réserves
en octobre 2007 la ville de rouen décide
de rendre aux autorités néo-zélandaises
qui en faisait la demande
une de ces têtes conservé dans son
muséum toutefois pour une question de
principe soulevée alors par la ministre
de la culture
cette délibération a fait l'objet d'un
recours qui a conduit à son annulation
par le juge
en effet la ville s'étaient fondés sur
les dispositions du code civil issu de
la loi bioéthique de 94 qui prévoit que
le corps humain ne peut faire l'objet
d'un droit patrimonial
cet argument a été rejeté par le juge
alors même je le rappelle quand même
alors même qu'au moment des débats sur
la bonus hottentote
c'est exactement l'argument utilisé par
le ministre de la recherche pour en
pré-séance ici refusé le principe de
restituer à l'afrique du sud
la vénus hottentote on voit bien qu'à
l'époque nous avions peut être raison
d'insister et ne pas nous laisser
convaincre par les arguments du
ministère s'agissant de la tête maorie
le juge a rappelé que le muséum de rouen
est en toc une d'appellation de musées
trois ans est régi par les dispositions
de la loi du 4 janvier 2002 or cette loi
dont j'étais l'un porteur au sénat
réaffirmé le principe de
l'inaliénabilité des biens des
collections des musées de france à
l'initiative de notre commission se doit
aussi prévu une possibilité strictement
encadrée de déclassement d'un de ses
biens après avis conforme une commission
scientifique
or cette commission
n'a pas été saisie au sujet de la tête
maorie elle n'a d'ailleurs jamais été
saisi de deux questions des classements
du tout j'y reviendrai plus loin
la proposition de loi permet donc de
déroger à cette procédure spécifique
prévue par la loi musée en sortant des
collections l'ensemble des têtes maories
conservées travail responsables de
musées ainsi que les éminents
scientifiques que j'ai entendu ces
dernières semaines m'ont conforté dans
l'idée que peu d'arguments valables
s'oppose à la restitution des têtes
maories plusieurs critères en justifie
le bien fondé d'abord comme me l'ont
confirmé
l'ambassadrice de nouvelle zélande et le
ministre de la culture néo zélandais
leur pays souhaite bien le retour des
têtes maories alors pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai insisté pour que la nouvelle
zélande où le confirme c'est parce que
lorsque nous avons débattu de la vénus
hottentote au dernier moment
le ministère nous avait fait dire mais
l'afrique du sud serait embêté si nous
rendions la dépouille de saartjie
baartman parce qu'en réalité ne le
demande pas ces sapins une demande
formelle j'ai donc souhaité que là aussi
la nouvelle zélande nous confirme le
souhait de permettre le retour de ses
ancêtres sur leur terre d'origine qui a
pour objet de leur offrir une sépulture
décente conforme aux rites ancestraux la
restitution ne justifie donc pas se
justifie donc au regard du principe de
dignité humaine de l'éthique mais aussi
du respect dû aux cultures et croyances
d'un peuple vivant enfin les têtes
maories son entrée dans les collections
de nos musées en tant qu'objet curiosité
une sur des fondements anthropologiques
fondée à l'époque sur des considérations
racistes
elles n'ont jamais fait l'objet en
france de recherche scientifique et de
la vie d'un éminent spécialiste
elle ne présente aucun intérêt au regard
des méthodes anthropologique actuelle
serait néanmoins souhaitable de
conserver la trace de ce témoignage
historique et culturel comme le
permettent les techniques actuelles de
numérisation pour ne pas aboutir à des
trous dans la connaissance de l'humanité
dont les musées sont aussi responsables
il me semble donc pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons que notre pays s'honorerait à
autoriser le retour de ces têtes maories
c'est une démarche éthique respectueuse
des valeurs humanistes de notre pays et
du dialogue
arts culturels à l'automne 2007 pour ces
mêmes raisons notre groupe d'amitié
france où les landes présidé par marcel
deneux avait fait part de son émotion à
l'égard de l'annulation de la
délibération d'habiles de rohan et
marquer son soutien à notre démarche
notre commission a donc souscrit à
l'initiative de catherine morin
dessailly en acceptant que les têtes
maories sortent des collections des
musées pour être remise à la nouvelle
zélande et je précise bien pour être
remise à la nouvelle zélande
il s'agit pas simplement de déclasser
c'est bien dans l'optique de rendre à la
nouvelle zélande
il reviendra aux responsables des musées
collectivités concernées de définir en
étroite coopération avec le musée te
papa et les autorités néo zélandaises
les modalités de cette restitution le
dialogue est essentiel
je ne nie pas toutefois les craintes que
la démarche initiée par notre collègue
suscité en particulier celle d'une
dérive vers une pente glissante entre
guillemets suscitant des revendications
de nature mettra à mal notre patrimoine
naturel
voilà bien vu qu'il n'ya pas eu une
pléthore de demandes depuis le dossier
aboutit de la vénus hottentote en 2002
les mêmes craintes
effectivement c'était déjà exprimé à ce
moment-là toutefois si ces questions
sont abordées avec une extrême prudence
je crois que nous aurions plus à perdre
qu'à gagner à les esquiver plus
longtemps il me semble que cette
réflexion est aujourd'hui attendu ou a
souhaité j'ai constaté une évolution
significative des mentalités par rapport
à 2002 tant chez les scientifiques que
chez les conservateurs
en effet je n'ai pas senti de véritable
opposition il n'y a pas eu de fronde
nida part des conservateurs ni de la
part du mouvement des journalistes or il
ya bien eu quelques passages qui me sont
consacrés pour me dire ça y est il s'est
déjà laisser entraîner vers une pente
glissante en acceptant une nouvelle fois
d'aller vers le déclassement de pièces
de collection mais je crois que ce sont
plutôt des combats de quelques-uns et
que l'essentiel de ce qui aujourd'hui
sont engagés dans ce débat sont
favorables à ce déclassement pour
permettre le retour des têtes maories en
mais les landes voilà j'ai donc proposé
à la commission des affaires culturelles
de compléter la proposition de loi pour
éviter d'avoir de nouveau à nous penser
à l'avenir sur un cas similaire à celui
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui est bien
vu j'ai proposé non simplement de donner
un avis favorable à ce qui est proposé
mais de compléter cette proposition du
rail me semble d'abord qu'une réflexion
est à conduire sur la gestion éthique
des collections des musées et notamment
des restes humains
quand on a des restes humains dans la
collection ce ne sont pas simplement des
pièces de deux collections quelconque ce
seul ce ne sont pas des oeuvres d'art
qui sont accrochées au mur
ce ne sont pas des pièces de vaisselle
dans une en il s'agit de restes humains
je crois qu'il est important qu'il y ait
une réflexion éthique à conduire les
personnes que j'ai auditionné ont
d'ailleurs souligné le retard de notre
pays de sur ces enjeux dans le cas du
récolement décennal obligatoire des
musées il serait précieux de parvenir à
un inventaire précis de ses collections
spécifiques qui restent encore trop
souvent une zone d'ombré des musées par
ailleurs il n'est pas normal que la
procédure de déclassement des biens des
collections des musées introduite à
notre initiative dans la loi soit restée
virtuelle cette procédure était pourtant
extrêmement prudent d encadrer certes
une commission scientifique nationale
des collections des musées de france a
été instituée elle a une triple vocation
puisqu'elle est chargée d'émettre un
avis sur les projets d'acquisitions et
restauration d'oeuvres et enfin sur le
demande de déclassement composé de 35
membres essentiellement des
professionnels des musées et
représentants de l'administration
elle est présidée par le directeur des
musées de france
madame or si cette commission a tenu
plusieurs réunions toutes consacrées à
des questions de restauration
d'acquisition elle n'a jamais dû à
statuer me semble-t-il sur problème de
déclassement cette commission n'a pas
davantage engagés de réflexion vue de
définir des critères en vue
d'éventuelles déclassement comme je
l'avais pourtant invitées à le faire au
moment des débats en séance publique
jacques rigaud a d'ailleurs confirmé
dans le rapport sur la question de
l'aliénation des oeuvres collections
publiques qu'il a remis à madame albanel
en février 2008 dans le cadre de la
réflexion que le président de la
république
et le premier ministre avait souhaité
ouvrir même si nous sommes extrêmement
attachés au principe fondamental
d'inaliénabilité des collections qui est
consubstantielle à la mission de service
public des musées une réflexion doit
néanmoins être conduites de façon
sincère de toute évidence cette
procédure de déclassement a vocation à
rester exceptionnelle et strictement
encadré aucun d'entre nous ne pourrait
avoir pour arrière-pensée le mettre en
péril l'intégrité de notre formidable
patrimoine artistique accumulés au cours
des siècles passés toutefois il nous
faut aussi elle sortir d'une vision
conservatrice qui ne tiennent compte ni
de la diversification des collections ni
de l'évolution de la conception musée
dans le cas des institutions à vocation
scientifique et technique par exemple et
en particulier des collections d'études
une conservation éternel n'est pas
toujours la plus adaptée d'autres cas
peuvent également se présenter et
nécessité de ménager quelques souplesses
sans avoir à en passer par la loi
la commission a donc décidé sur ma
proposition est un accord avec l'auteur
de la proposition de loi de compléter ce
texte en vue de réactiver cette
procédure de déclassement tout en
l'encadrant de fortes précaution le
texte adopté par notre commission ne
crée pas une nouvelle commission
puisqu'il s'agit seulement de
redimensionner la commission instituée
par la loi de 2002 afin de la rendre
opérationnelle
nous proposons dans l'énergie la
composition et de les confier des
missions et une feuille de route plus
précise
renommé commission nationale
scientifique des collections son champ
de compétence s'étend en outre au delà
des seuls collections des musées de
france
la procédure de déclassement serait
notamment étendu aux oeuvres du fonds
national d'art contemporain et la
commission pourrait être également
conseiller les personnes privées
gestionnaire de fonds régionaux d'art
contemporain ce qui rejoint les
préconisations du rapport rigaux j
insiste cependant sur le fait que ces
collections contemporaines sont aussi
celles pour lesquelles le principe
d'inaliénabilité a sans doute le plus ce
sens les déclassements peuvent toutefois
être justifié dans certains cas
exceptionnels
par exemple en cas de très forte
dégradation de l'oeuvre la commission
regrette également vocation à définir
des recommandations et une forme de
doctrine générale cohérente et
responsable en matière de déclassement
permettant d'éclairer les propriétaires
et gestes
une aire de collection dans leur
décision elle devra rendre compte de ses
réflexions sur ce sujet devant le
parlement
en remettant un rapport dans un délai
d'un an à compter de la publication de
la loi
bien sûr la question des restes humains
doivent faire l'objet d'un examen
scientifique approfondi dans ce cadre
car il s'agit d'une question éthique
particulièrement sensible et complexe
compte tenu de l'élargissement de ses
missions et de l'importance des enjeux
sur lesquels elle aura à se pencher la
composition de cette commission est
élargie au delà des professionnels de la
conservation à la représentation
nationale aux représentants de l'état et
des collectivités territoriales
en tant que propriétaire de collections
publiques à des personnalités qualifiées
représentant notamment diverses
disciplines scientifiques comme
l'anthropologie l'ethnologie la
philosophie en effet pour parler
éthiques
nous pensons que ce ne sont pas
uniquement les conservateurs des musées
qui sont les mieux placés pour le faire
par cohérence avec ses apports notre
commission a modifié enfin l'intitulé de
cette proposition de loi
voici donc monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues monsieur le président
les objectifs du texte que notre
commission a examiné avec la plus grande
attention et qu'elle vous propose à
présent d'adopter nous avons complété
pour que soient poursuivis
une réflexion que nous considérons comme
importante c'est un nouveau chantier qui
s'ouvre pour notre politique culturelle
et patrimoniale et nous souhaitons
vivement monsieur le ministre et de
votre ministère sont en part pour que
cette proposition de loi puisse être
adoptées et mises en oeuvre dans les
meilleurs délais avec j'en suis sûr de
la part des habitants de la part de la
population de la part du gouvernement de
nouvelle zélande
une attention qui sera très particulière
et une décision qui est aujourd'hui très
attendu de l'autre côté des océans ne
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à monsieur frédéric
mitterrand ministre de la culture et de
la communication je vous salue monsieur
le ministre au nom du sénat pour votre
première intervention dans un débat
devant la haute assemblée
je vous en prie
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice mme sur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
la question qui nous est posée à
l'occasion de l'examen de la présente
proposition de loi celle de
l'appartenance de restes humains aux
collections des musées de france et de
celles qui attise la controverse des
prises de positions morales nous avons
tous en mémoire les échanges
passionnants auxquels a donné lieu
notamment au sein de votre haute
assemblée la remise à l'afrique du sud
des restes de saartjie baartman dit la
vénus hottentote
plus récemment en 2007 la tête maorie
inscrits sur les inventaires du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de rouen a remis
sous les feux de l'actualité
les problèmes posés par la conservation
et éventuellement la présentation des
restes humains conservés dans les
collections publiques
deux conceptions sont possibles au sujet
des éléments du corps humain entré dans
les collections des musées
la première se focalise sur la violence
qui est à l'origine de ce que l'on nomme
faute d'expression plus digne les restes
humains
cette violence peut être médicale
derrière ou rituelles une telle
conception amènent à douter de la
possibilité même de transformer un
élément du corps humain en objets de
collection
la seconde vision replace les restes
humains conservés dans les collections
publiques dans un contexte plus large
elle englobe les motifs variés le plus
souvent scientifiques ou historiques
parfois culturelles qui ont justifié un
moment donné une protection particulière
de ces objets je crois que ces deux
conceptions peuvent être conciliées
c'est d'ailleurs le semble-t-il le
sentiment général
personne ne songe en effet à remettre en
cause l'intérêt de conserver et de
présenter au public par exemple les
momies égyptiennes du louvre les musées
égyptiens eux-mêmes les expose dans un
espace soumis à une tarification
complémentaire sans y voir de
contradiction avec le respect dû à la
dignité du corps humain je suis donc
particulièrement honorés pour ma
première intervention devant votre haute
assemblée en tant que ministre de la
culture et de la communication de
prendre part à ce débat essentiel pour
les collections publiques françaises
je le souhaite apaiser et équilibrée
nous allons tous ensemble tenter de
concilier d'une part la nécessité
éthique d'apporter une réponse aux
demandes des communautés d'origine des
têtes maories et d'autre part
l'attachement qui est le nôtre à
l'intégrité des collections publiques et
aux principes d'in d'inaliénabilité que
sa traduction juridique
j'en viens d'abord au traitement du cas
très particuliers qui constituent des
têtes maories objet de l'article 1er de
la proposition de loi
l'histoire de ces artefacts c'est bien
connu
elle a été rappelée il y encore quelques
instants à l'origine pratique rituelle
témoignant du respect du tribu et d'une
famille envers ses morts la momification
des têtes est devenue sous l'effet de la
terre
des macabre des voyageurs et des
collectionneurs européens l'objet d'un
commerce particulièrement barbare
le gouvernement partage pleinement souci
éthique qui fondent la démarche de
l'auteur et du rapporteur de la
proposition de loi
je tiens d'ailleurs à rappeler qu aucun
moment le gouvernement n'a pris position
sur l'opportunité de la remise aux
autorités de nouvelle-zélande de la tête
maorie du muséum droit l'intervention de
l'état auprès du juge administratif
était simplement simplement motivés dans
le cadre de l'exercice du contrôle de
légalité par la nécessité d'assurer le
respect des procédures dont le
législateur a entouré le déclassement
des objets appartenant aux prédictions
des musées de france et airbus en
l'occurrence la saisine pour avis de la
commission scientifique
institué par la loi de 4 janvier 2002
sur les musées de france sur l'intérêt
de conserver les têtes dans les
collections publiques je tiens à saluer
la finesse d'analysé du rapporteur
après avoir rappelé qu'elle n'était
entré dans les collections que comme
objet de curiosité et non d'étude
scientifique monsieur richter a présenté
le problème dans toute sa complexité et
son éternelle selon les témoignages
recueillis par le rapporteur
les têtes conservés dans nos musées
n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'études
poussées et ne présentent pas beaucoup
d'intérêt au regard des méthodes
anthropologique actuelle cependant comme
le souligne également le rapporteur il
convient d'en garder une trace pour ne
pas laisser vide dans la connaissance de
l'humanité et encore moins dans la
mémoire de cet épisode peu glorieux de
l'histoire d'expansion européenne sur
les mollets y sont des modalités
juridiques choisi pour favoriser la
remise des têtes maories aux autorités
néo zélandaises
votre commission a retenu une solution
sage respectueuse de la liberté de
chacune des collectivités publiques état
ou commune propriétaire des têtes
maories
en effet son application de l'article 1
de la proposition de loi
les têtes maories seront immédiatement
de faire partie des collections des
musées de france en vue de leur remise à
la nouvelle zélande
il reviendra à chaque collectivité
propriétaire de procéder à leur
déclassement et de négocier les
modalités de leur remise avec les
autorités néo zélandaises les musées
concernés des grandes métropoles
régionales celui de rouen bien sûr mais
aussi marseille lyon lille ou la
rochelle auront ainsi la possibilité
d'accomplir ce geste éthiques
je soulignerai simplement que pour la
première fois la loi organise la sortie
des collections des musées de france
d'une catégorie entière d'éléments et
non d'un objet déterminé pour l'avenir
je crois qu'il est capital de nous
donner de nous doter des moyens de
prévenir et de régler très en amont et
de façon consensuelle notamment entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales ou leurs établissements
sans avoir besoin de recourir aux
législateurs les difficultés qui
pourraient s'élever au sujet d'autres
cas particulier c'est précisément
l'objet des articles suivants de la
proposition de loi a ajouté par votre
commission des affaires culturelles ce
faisant
celle ci a souhaité saisir votre haute
assemblée de la question générale des
modalités de déclassement des objets
appartenant aux collections publiques le
gouvernement tient à saluer le caractère
très opportun de ces tunisiens
ti vct elle s'inscrit dans la droite
ligne des conclusions remises par
monsieur jacques rigaud au ministre de
la culture de la communication en
février 2008
concernant la modernisation de la
gestion des collections publiques dans
son rapport monsieur jacques rigaud
réaffirmé avec force le caractère
incontournable du principe
d'inaliénabilité l'inaliénabilité se
trouve en effet au fond d'eux mêmes au
fondement même des collections publiques
qui s'inscrivent dans un horizon
temporel de très long terme
elle a contribué au fil des siècles à la
constitution d'un patrimoine qui fait
aujourd'hui la fierté et l'attrait de
nos institutions culturelles
c'est jacques rigaud avait cependant
souligné la nécessité d'une véritable
respiration des collections dont l'usagé
possibilité de déclassement offertes par
le code du patrimoine était une modalité
envisageable
l'une des propositions du rapport rigaud
consistait donc à donner toute sa portée
à la loi relative aux musées de france
qui prévoit une procédure de
déclassement restée lettre morte jusqu'à
ce jour l'initiative de votre commission
des affaires culturelles vient ainsi
relayer un objectif du ministère de la
culture
la future commission scientifique
nationale des collections ainsi créée
par la proposition de loi traduira dans
sa composition toute la complexité des
questions de déclassement qui sont à la
fois scientifique culturelle et éthiques
la compétence primordial des
professionnels de la conservation des
collections sera ainsi complété par le
point de vue des parlementaires des
collectivités propriétaires des
collections ainsi que par celui de
personnalités éminentes dans d'autres
disciplines
utile à l'examen des projets de
déclassement philosophie droit
anthropologie etc
cette ouverture de la commission
scientifique nationale représentant de
la nation souligne la solennité de la
procédure de déclassement et témoigne de
l'attachement du parlement au principe
d'inaliénabilité par ailleurs la
proposition de loi en étendant aux
autres collections publiques au fonds
national d'un contemporaine ainsi qu'aux
collections des fonds régionaux d'art
contemporain l'intervention obligatoire
ou facultative de la commission
scientifique nationale favorise la prise
en compte de l'intérêt scientifique et
culturel des biens concernés au moment
de faire le choix de déclassés ou non je
sais gré également aux sénateurs de la
commission d'avoir pour les demandes de
déclassement de biens appartenant aux
collections publiques étendu la
procédure de l'avis conforme prévus par
la loi sur les musées de france
celle ci garantit en effet la prise en
compte par les propriétaires des
collections de l' expertise et de la
représentativité de cette instance
ce périmètre élargi permettra également
jean forme le voeu de définir une
doctrine générale pour l'ensemble des
collections publiques
cette proposition de loi vient de clore
de façon particulièrement heureuse
la controverse suscitée à l'automne 2007
par la lune à sion de la délibération de
la ville de rouen relative à la
restitution de la tête maorie
elle marque surtout l'ouverture trop
longtemps retardée à mes yeux
d'un véritable débat de fond sur le
recours au déclassement
car elle donne aux collectivités
publiques et moyens de disposer en la
matière d'une doctrine définie en
parfaite concertation
la proposition de loi d'un en effet
compétences à la commission scientifique
pour fixer la doctrine et les critères
qui permettront précisément la
respiration des collections sans en
compromettre l'intégrité ni amoindrir la
portée du principe d'inaliénabilité ces
lignes directrices seront très
rapidement présentés dans le rapport qui
devrait être remis au parlement dans un
raid délai relativement court d'un homme
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons le
gouvernement est amené à émettre un avis
favorable sur cette proposition de bois
je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
votre attention je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je vous informe
chaque n'est que pour la discussion
générale à nous appliquons pour la
première fois
l'alinéa 5 de l'article 29 terre de
notre règlement tel qu'il résulte de la
résolution du 2 juin les groupes autres
que ceux auxquels appartiennent les
représentants des commissions désigne
chacun premier orateur des orateurs
ainsi désigné interviennent à la suite
des commissions selon l'ordre de tirage
au sort dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur
nicolas alfonsi pour le groupe rdse
chers collègues
je
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
quand m et moi mon tour de vous
souhaiter la bienvenue au sénat et
d'exprimer le voeu d'une collaboration
fructueuse avec la haute assemblée chers
collègues le des vingt ans aujourd'hui
de la proposition de loi de notre
collègue qui vient de s'exprimer à
l'instant et je voudrais rapplique
depuis vingt ans des gens
la nouvelle zélande et réclament le
retour au pays et est mort
cette démarche est plus que légitime
puisqu'il est inspiré par le souhait de
récupérer ces restes humains considérés
comme sacrés pour leur accorder une
sépulture digne et respectueuse des
coutumes des ancêtres nouri 7 est mamie
ciel est tatoué des ancêtres l'ont ory
avait fait l'objet de trafics
commerciaux dans des collectionneurs
européens et américains jusqu'à la fin
du 19e siècle en france nous en pensée
dans une quinzaine dans des collections
publiques
outre celle de rouen qui a suscité
l'initiative de notre collègue ses
dettes qui ne sont pas ou qui ne sont
plus exposés comme au musée du quai
branly qui on pensait pourtant 80 6 à 8
n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'études
scientifiques particulières par la
musique les concerts dans des réserves
de leurs collections à travers le monde
plusieurs états et institutions déjà
restitué les têtes maories et notre
démarche
aujourd'hui est aussi guidé par ses
gestes morale éthique exemplaires
cependant ce débat ouvre un autre plus
large et plus inquiétant si l'on peut
s'empêcher de reconnaître les erreurs
passées
souvent perpétuer au nom de la science
pour appuyer le retour en nouvelle
zélande de crâne momifié
certains redoutent que cela fuse
ouvrir des brèches et que la restitution
des têtes n'en rit crée un précédent et
puisse alors potentiellement ouvert la
voie à un déploiement progressif et
inexorable des collections nationales
quand c'est rapide par exemple des
momies précieusement conservés exposé au
musée du louvre où de nombreuses
reliques des saints que nous procédons à
travers l'hexagone en ce geste éthique
respectueux de la dignité de l'homme et
des cultures et croyances d'un peuple
vivant inspiré sans doute aussi par le
poids de la culpabilité de l'histoire
coloniale ne doit absolument pas
remettre en cause le principe
d'inaliénabilité des collections
nationales la règle intangible doit
rester celle du caractère inaliénable
des oeuvres d'art aujourd'hui le
rapporteur dans le sol ont la qualité du
rapport nous propose de compléter d'un
disposition nature à éviter d'avoir à
nouveau recours à la loi pour ce type de
problème nous avons en effet déjà dû
légiférer en 2002 sur un cas similaire
cela a déjà été évoqué celui d'un
dépouille mortelle de charge du batman
dit vêtu de hottentote restituer à
l'afrique du sud
dans les faits la dérive des jarres et
de 2 à l'époque tu s'est pas vérifié si
nous avons nous de nous vous légiférez
aujourd'hui cela prouve bien que la
procédure administrative instaurée en
dans le cas du patrimoine pour le
déclassement des biens constituant des
mots des collections des musées de
france manque totalement d'efficacité on
nous propose pour y remédier et
d'élargir la commission nationale
scientifique sur le déclassement des
oeuvres à des personnalités qualifiées
dans le domaine de l'éthique des élus
des scientifiques et d'étendre son champ
de compétence en lançant des
collectivités publiques voire privés
au delà des seuls collections des musées
de france
mais et c'est là l'essentiel
le texte propose de définir clairement
les missions de cette commission
jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'a nullement fait
avancer la réflexion sur les cas de
déclassement et demi sur les exceptions
que l'on pourra tolérer au principe
d'inaliénabilité des oeuvres d'art or ce
travail est fondamentale
si l'on souhaite pouvoir concilier les
objectifs de protection de notre
patrimoine culturel d'une part et de
respect de la dignité humaine de toutes
les cultures d'autres ports la france
accuse donc un retard dans la réflexion
engagée sur la gestion éthique des
collections des musées
c'est pourquoi si la proposition de loi
est adopté la commission nationale
scientifique son déclassement des
oeuvres devra évoquer une doctrine
générale en matière de déclassement et
des cessions elle devra également même
rendre compte de ses conclusions au
parlement lui remettant un rapport dans
un an puisque l'objectif de claire de
cette proposition de loi est bien de
faire le point sur la politique de
gestion éthique des collections
d'oeuvres d'art françaises et ce tout en
protégeant ceux qui doit être rester la
règle intangible à savoir le caractère
inaliénable des oeuvres d'art je me
réjouis de la beauté avec l'ensemble du
groupe rdse vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à monsieur serge lagauche
pour le groupe socialiste
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi de notre collecte
madame catherine morin desailly a une
portée bien plus large que la seule
résolution du conflit juridique entre
les tribunes administrative de roi et sa
municipalité
ce texte autorise non seulement la
restitution par la france à la nouvelle
zélande de l'ensemble des têtes maories
conservées par l'ensemble des musées de
france est encore l exposé des niches
l'acteur que nous sommes à la résolution
d'un conflit de principe
il nous appartient ainsi de concilier le
principe fondamental parce que garant de
notre patrimoine historique scientifique
artistique de ligne l'habilité des
collections publiques tout en adoptant
une démarche éthique fondée sur le
principe de dignité de l'homme du
respect des cultures et des croyances
d'un peuple vivant le programme néo
zélandais de rapatriement des dépouilles
marie mises en oeuvre depuis 1992 auprès
de l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
traduit l'importance que revêt pour le
pote marie le retour de ses ancêtres sur
leur terre d'origine pour les maris
l'ensemble des parties du corps présente
en effet un caractère sacré car elle
porte en elle les sens de la personne la
tête des maris d'élite et par la suite
de certains esclaves totalement à tous
et est considéré comme un parti la plus
sacrée du corps afin qu'elles ne fassent
l'objet d'une convoitise insupportable
et d'un commerce barbare de la part des
colons européens
c'était été conservé par les familles
des défunts mari en témoignage de
respect permettent la restitution par la
france des têtes man ray est donc un
impératif éthique et le groupe
socialiste du sénat souffrit pleinement
aux objectifs poursuivis par la
proposition de loi de madame morin
desailly pour autant comme pour la vénus
hottentote
il nous faut concilier cet impératif
éthique avec la règle juridique de ligne
à l'humilité des collections publiques
et autant que faire se peut agréer
définitivement ce conflit principe si la
question se pose est une nouvelle fois
un état seraient demain fondée à
demander la restitution d'une oeuvre
d'un objet originaire de son territoire
acquis de façon contestable par la
france
mais faisant partie des collections
publiques depuis souvent plusieurs
siècles comprenons nous bien il ne
s'agit pas d'adopter une attitude
protectionniste de repli sur soi voire
de méfiance en défendant les acquis des
conquêtes
aujourd'hui certes contestable mais qui
son histoire il s'agit au contraire de
conforter nos musées nationaux dans leur
mission d'exposition bien entendu mais
également de conservation et de
recherche
il nous faut créer les conditions
juridiques permettant à nos musées de
s'ouvrir sur l'extérieur en suivant les
évolutions sociologiques du monde tout
en les confortant dans leur mission de
gardien du patrimoine culturel national
la loi du 4 juillet 2002 relative aux
musées de france avait posé les bases
d'une règle permettant de faire le lien
entre les principes qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui confie lié celui éthique du
respect de la dignité humaine
d'un côté et celui juridique de l'est
n'est habilité des collections publiques
de l'hôte
malheureusement bien qu'intégré à la loi
sur les musées de france cette
possibilité d'extraire un bien du
domaine public pour envisager notamment
une cession est restée virtuelle la
commission scientifique nationale des
collections des musées de france
instituée par décret du 25 avril 2002 et
mis en place en 2003 a bien hâte eb
depuis tenue chaque année les réunions
mais n a jamais eu à statuer sur un
problème de déclassement elle n'a pas
davantage engagés de réflexion en vue de
définir des critères pour d'éventuels
déclassement quelles que soient les
ventes eu l inertie des institutions
muséales d'ailleurs dénoncée par
monsieur riche et dans son rapport il
était nécessaire de rectifier cette
procédure de déclassement tout en
l'encadrant de propres de précaution
c'est donc de manière fort opportune
comme ceux richert dans le cadre des
conclusions de la commission des
affaires culturelles que nous examinons
aujourd'hui a souhaité compléter la
proposition de loi de madame morin de
seuils renommée commission nationale
scientifique des collections aux
articles 2 et 3 nouveaux la commission
voit désormais ses missions préciser et
clarifier ainsi que son stand compétence
est large
concernant la proposition d'ouvrir de
nouvelles possibilités de transfert de
propriété d'oeuvre inscrits sur
l'inventaire du fonds national d'art
contemporain et mise en dépôt auprès des
collectivités
territoriale notre rapporteur du fait de
nos réticences sur cet amendement a
accepté de le retirer
faisant preuve d'un esprit d'ouverture
des consensus qui convient de souligner
vous l'aurez compris monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
socialiste du sénat estime que
l'ensemble des conditions requises pour
voter ce texte sont réunies nous
estimons cependant une réflexion reste à
conduire sur la gestion éthique des
collections des musées notamment sur le
statut des restes humains qui sont
présents ces sujets sont bien entendu
sensibles et complexes et la france est
très en retard sur ces questions
l'interdiction de l'exposition our body
à paris nous a montré la nécessité
d'accompagner les professionnels des
musées conservateurs et restaurateurs
puisse ce texte et les nouvelles
missions confiées à la commission
scientifique nationale des collections
constituer une première étape de cette
réflexion vous remercie chers collègues
la parole et à monsieur nicolas be
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre à mon tour je vous souhaite la
bienvenue mais c'est le rapporteur
madame la sénatrice hauteur de la
proposition
mes chers collègues sept ans après le
vote de la loi portant la restitution de
la dépouille mortelle de cergy baartman
à l'afrique du sud
nous voici de nouveau réunis rien n'a
changé nous sommes confrontés aux mêmes
interrogations aux mêmes
incompréhensions et j'allais dire au
même résistance que nous avions alors
rencontré il y à 7 ans il avait fallu en
passer par le vote d'une loi pour régler
un litige que l'administration française
n'avait pas si vous n'avez pas voulu
résoudre dignement
alors que la france n'avait pas honoré
sa promesse de restitution faite
oralement dix ans plus tôt par le
président de la république françois
mitterrand
un monsieur nelson mandela le refus de
la france de rendre sargis baartman aux
siens qu'il a réclamée ne faisait que
réveiller un peu plus les blessures d'un
peuple trop longtemps écrasée sous le
joug des humiliations de l'exploitation
et de l'asservissement aux pires heures
du colonialisme très rapidement lors des
débats qui ont lieu au sénat tout le
monde y compris le ministre avait fini
par admettre l'inutilité juridique du
recours à la loi
alors que certains affirmer le caractère
inaliénable des biens appartenant aux
collections publiques des musées 16 ans
de la france la propriétaire des restes
de cergy batman le ministre de la
recherche d' alors monsieur charles
manson berg avait confirmé ce que
j'avançais qu'en vertu des lois de
bioéthique de 1994
nul ne pouvait se déclarer propriétaire
d'un élément du corps humain la france
n'était en réalité que la gardienne de
la dépouille de madame baartman bien
mauvaise gardienne au demeurant puisque
squelettes et des organes comme le
rappelait le rapporteur pour hisser au
fond de la remise du musée de l'homme à
paris depuis 1974 ce musée avait du
reste prudemment retirer de ses vitrines
des restes de la vénus hottentote
conscient sans doute de l'inadéquation
de l'indécence d'une telle exposition
aux yeux du grand public celle du corps
d'une femme noire à la physionomie hors
du commun
exhibées tel un phénomène de siècle il
faut dire que de telles expositions de
spécimens humains étaient fréquentes au
19e siècle et traduisez une idéologie
scientifique fondée sur une plaie ses
hésitations de l'être humain
selon dekra des critères raciaux
supposée qui fort heureusement n'ont
plus cours aujourd'hui dans les musées
comme dans les expéditions des
exhibitions public second qualifie
dunant terrible de zoos humains qui
avait lieu lors des expositions
universelles l'existence même d'une
vitrine de musées ou d'une simple grille
trahit une idéologie qu'il nous faut
désormais absolument rejetée elle trace
en effet une frontière invisible mais
tangible entre eux et nous peu c'est à
dire les dépouilles où les restes
humains de peuples dits primitifs exhibé
comme des trop c est nous peuple
occidental peuple de découvreurs peuvent
se disant supérieure peuple de
conquérant il nous faut comprendre ce
que ressentent les descendants de ces
peuples lorsqu'ils apprennent la
survivance de restes de leurs proches
dans cette dans nos musées français
transposons un instant la situation que
ressentent irions nous si nous
apprenions que quelque part dans le
monde des têtes de soldats français ou
autres étaient exposées derrière des
vitrines des musées avouons le il y a
quelque chose d'insupportable pour nous
dans cette vision d'horreur
et pourtant quelle différence
existe-t-il vraiment le don des têtes
maories à la france ne date que de 1875
est précisément ce sont des crânes de
guerriers des chefs de village de
personnages de haut rang et bien pour le
peuple maori dette insupportable
de savoir que les restes de leurs
ancêtres illustres sont exposées ainsi
dans les musées français
il faut dire que ces exhibitions réactif
des blessures anciennes alors que les
tribus maories constituent les premières
populations natives des îles de nouvelle
zélande et de leurs principaux ziegler
presse aux occupants pendant près de dix
siècles elles ont été littéralement
décimé au 19e siècle par l'arrivée des
colons européens
l'introduction d'armes à feu sur le
territoire néo zélandais conduisit en
effet à des guerres inter tribal
sanglant il en résulta une véritable
extermination de certaines tribus des
déportations qu'elle s'ajouter à des
épidémies apportées par les européens
enfin la couronne britannique pris
prétexte des rébellions provoqué par
l'achat contestée de terre pour
confisquer de vastes parcelles aux
tribus maories à titre de représailles
après la perte de leur terre les maoris
sont alors entrés dans une période de
déclin si bien qu'on crut à leur
disparition complète la découverte au
sein des villages décimer des têtes
maories qui constituait pour ses pubs
des objets sacrés comme des trophées de
guerre firent alors l'objet de trafics
sordides notre excellente collègue
catherine morin dessailly auteur de la
proposition de loi nous rapporte même
que des esclaves qui n'était donc pas
des chefs guerriers ont été tatoué à
seule fin d'être ensuite décapités pour
faire l'objet des changes ces
traitements barbares font frémir
nous ne sommes pas directement
responsable des malheurs du peuple maori
tout comme nous ne l'étions pas du
peuple koizan auquel appartenait la
vénus hottentote
mais nous serions coupable si nous
continuons à conserver des reliques
maori sans plus aucun intérêt
scientifique dans les remises de nos
musées il est du moindre de nos devoirs
des décès peuple a tourné la page d'une
histoire récente et douloureuse
bien entendu une telle restitution d'un
s'entourer d'un certain nombre de
précautions
loin de moi l'idée d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore de tous les musées de france
il ne s'agit pas ici d'initier une
jurisprudence qui consisterait à rendre
alors supposé descendants tous les
ossements de la préhistoire ou
toutes les momies de l'egypte ancienne
même si nous devons de nous devons de
conserver et de présenter ces restes
humains dans les conditions
respectueuses dignes et décentes
nous parlons ici d'une histoire quasi
contemporaine deux peuples en pleine
reconstruction identitaire qui cherche à
sauvegarder leur culture à préserver
leurs rites à rendre leur dignité à
leurs ancêtres
il s'agit ici d'entendre la demande de
gens qui ont souffert dans leur histoire
récente et qui s'identifient à ces
reliques en leur restituant leurs
ancêtres nous devons les aider à tirer
un trait sur les querelles et des
tensions qui ont pu les opposés par le
passé à ce qu'ils considéraient comme
des occupants
je tiens à signaler enfin que par
expérience j'ai pu mesurer à quel point
la restitution d'une dépouille mortelle
qui a fait l'objet d'une demande
officielle par le gouvernement de son
pays d'origine avait permis de
réchauffer de manière très significative
des relations diplomatiques entre notre
pays et le pays demandeur ce que
montrent ont confirmé de nombreux
diplomates français sud africain à
l'issue de la sphère de la vénus
hottentote
il n'est d'ailleurs pas inutile de
rappeler que nombreux pays tels que les
etats-unis la suisse le royaume-uni le
danemark ou l'argentine ont déjà
enclenché une vaste un vaste mouvement
de restitution des têtes maories à la
nouvelle zélande
il serait incompréhensible que la france
reste à l'écart de cette dynamique
c'est également la raison pour laquelle
je m'inscris totalement dans la démarche
qui consiste à choisir comme critère
principal pour faire droit à la demande
de restitution
le fait que cette demande émane bien des
autorités gouvernementales du pays
d'origine et non pas de l'une ou l'autre
tribu qui en revendique la filiation
il convient en effet d'éviter en
attribuant sans discernement ces restes
humains de réactiver des conflits
ethniques ou revendicatif au sein d'une
nation
personnellement je serais assez
favorable à la création d'une instance
internationale qui serait chargée de se
prononcer sur le bien fondé des demandes
de restitution des dépouilles humaines
dans les musées indépendamment des avis
des états
cette instance indépendante serait
composé de hautes personnalités
d'experts reconnus d'anthropologues
d'ethnologue de généticiens et
d'historiens elle pourrait être
rattachée à l'onu ou à l'unesco
car il ne s'agit pas là de défendre un
bien ou une oeuvre d'art relevant du
droit patrimonial d'un état mais bien
d'assurer le respect la dignité qu'ils
sont universellement reconnus à
l'ensemble de l'humanité
et puisqu'il s'agit de respect de
dignité
je tiens à série 6 le point sur les
questions juridiques que soulève de
manière récurrente les demandes de
restitution
je sais que certains ont pu écrire ici
ou là en particulier certains chercheurs
anthropologue que les lois de bioéthique
ne concernait en réalité que l'être
humain vivant et serait pour cela
inadapté au cas des restes humains donc
mort traités par les musées endroits il
est vrai seule la personne vivante est
considéré comme sujet de droit
selon ses auteurs les lois de bioéthique
de 94 protégerait avant tout la personne
vivante dans son intégrité physique et
morale
par exemple contre les expérimentations
le trafic d'organes
de même les articles 16 à 16 9 du code
civil relatif à la protection du corps
humain ne concernerait que la personne
vivante jusqu'à son décès en posant le
principe de l'inviolabilité de
l'indisponibilité de son corps en tant
que personne pour le commerce ou le
droit patrimonial aux personnes qui
agite de tels arguments juridiques je
veux rappeler après l'auteur de la
proposition
une jurisprudence récente mes chers
collègues vous souvenez d'expositions
organisées au printemps dernier à
l'espace madeleine à paris celle ci
consistait à présenter d'anatomie 17
cadavres d'origine chinoise
or cette exposition était interdite par
une ordonnance de référé rendue par le
président du tribunal de grande instance
de paris puis confirmée par la cour
d'appel de paris
dans son ordonnance le juge en effet
estimé que cette exposition représentait
une atteinte illicite au corps humain et
que les mises en scènes déréalisantes de
ces corps manquaient de décence l'espace
assigné par la loi au cadavre appel le
juge et le cimetière
en réalité cette interdiction était
prononcée en application des
dispositions de l'article 16-1-1 du code
civil
ces dispositions ont été introduites par
la loi du 19 décembre 2008 relative à j
station funéraire en vertu de laquelle
le respect dû au corps humain ne cesse
pas avec la mort et que les restes des
personnes décédées doivent être traités
avec respect dignité et décence
au vu de la législation confirmée par la
jurisprudence
on ne peut donc plus dire que les restes
humains peuvent constituer des objets du
musée comme les autres en tant
qu'élément du corps humain ils méritent
respect dignité et décence et leur place
n'est plus derrière une vitrine de musée
mais bien dans un cimetière
les têtes maories n'échappe pas à cette
règle
compte tenu des dimensions identitaire
symbolique diplomatiques et juridiques
de cette affaire
il faut donc mes chers collègues sert
droit à la demande de restitution des
têtes maories exprimée par la nouvelle
zélande
laissons-les repartir et reposez en paix
dans leur terre natale qui les attend
afin que puissent y être inhumés
dignement
c'est à dire par leur peuple selon les
rites ancestraux
puissions-nous mes chers collègues un
instant fait résonner en nous la voix du
peuple maori qui nous rappelle dans l'un
de ces proverbes anciens la terre est
une mère qui ne meurent jamais merci
je remercie chaque collègue la parole et
à madame odette terrade dans le groupe
crc spg
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est au nom de mon collègue du bon
renard sénateur du nord avec qui j'avais
cosigné la proposition de loi notre
collègue mme morin dessailly que
j'interviens aujourd'hui je constate que
dans le cadre des débats sur la
bioéthique par exemple les citoyens se
montre particulièrement sensible au
respect de la dignité de la personne
humaine est rétif à tout ce qui
s'apparente à sa marchandisation et on
ne peut valablement s'interroger sur la
vie et sans questionner également le
rapport des vivants à la mort c'est
pourquoi notre assemblée s'honore en
permettant la restitution à la nouvelle
zélande qui les réclament des têtes
maories conservées par les musées de
france
d'autant que cela a été rappelé
précédemment
elles sont parvenues dans notre pays
dans un contexte colonialiste et raciste
ou les peuples non occidentaux étaient
considérées comme inférieures avec à la
clé des massacres et des trafics
sordides
ces têtes maories pourront ainsi être
inhumer dignement dans le respect des
rites funéraires de ce peuple
on ne peut ignorer que le respect des
dépouilles mortelles dans la diversité
des coutumes ancestrales a profondément
contribué à humaniser les sociétés mais
aussi à civiliser les hommes la
mythologie grecque par exemple évoque
les croyances et les lois parfois non
écrite qu'il est essentiel de ne pas
transgresser ainsi d'antigone qui décide
au péril de sa vie de rendre les
honneurs funèbres à son frère malgré
l'interdiction du roi créon antigone
n'est elle pas un beau symbole de la
nécessité ontologique d'offrir une
sépulture digne au défunt le fait que la
décision prise par le conseil municipal
de rouen et susciter un tel débat à la
fois éthique et juridique sur ces têtes
maories témoignent des lacunes et du
retard de notre réflexion sur ces
questions
aussi notre groupe sera particulièrement
vigilant quant à
réactivation indispensable de la
procédure de déclassement des biens
appartenant aux collections publiques
introduite dans la loi musée de 2002
mais malheureusement demeurer virtuel
nous avons perdu beaucoup de temps et il
est tout à fait essentiel tout en
confortant la portée du principe
d'inaliénabilité auquel nous sommes très
attachés de disposer de critères clairs
en la matière nous soutenons également
la proposition de ne pas limiter la
composition de la commission spécifique
chargé du déclassement aux seuls
professionnels de la conservation
on ne peut réduire les restes humains à
de simples objets de collection et l'
approche éthique dépasse les seules
considérations patrimoniales ou
scientifique
c'est pourquoi il est tout à fait
pertinent d'ouvrir cette commission à
des personnalités qualifiées en
particulier comme on représentants de
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales ainsi qu'un parlementaire
de chacune des deux assemblées
notre groupe sera donc particulièrement
attentifs à l'application de l'article 4
qui donne en quelque sorte rendez vous
au parlement dans un an afin de
s'assurer de l'avancé concrète des
travaux de cette commission scientifique
des collections en matière de
déplacements ou de cession alors que de
nombreux musées américains australiens
et européens ont déjà donné leur feu
vert à cette demande des plus légitimes
de la nouvelle zélande
il y a urgence à ce que notre pays
éclaircir sa position sur le statut des
biens issus du corps humain après le
précédent de la vénus hottentote il y à
7 ans le débat sur les têtes maories
aujourd'hui il est important qu'à
l'avenir les musées français puissent
répondre sereinement aux nouvelles
demandes de restitution et qu'il ne soit
plus nécessaire de légiférer si de
telles nouvelles situation équivalente
des situations équivalente se présente
permettre que les morts reposent en paix
n'est-il pas une condition pour que les
vivants eux mêmes vive en paix c'est une
question d'autant plus universel
que si on remonte à l'origine de
l'univers nous avons tous les mêmes les
mêmes ancêtres
si c'est avec ivan renar que nous avions
signé cosigné cette proposition nous
avons été donc deux sénateurs de notre
groupe a signé cette ppl
mais c'est bien l'ensemble du groupe crc
spg qui est favorable à la restitution
de ces têtes maories et ce d'autant plus
que cette restitution participe
pleinement du dialogue et des échanges
interculturels que nous avons toujours
encouragé
je me réjouis donc pour le peuple maori
qui pourra ainsi donner à ses ancêtres
une sépulture conforme à leur culture et
leurs traditions
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous avez compris que mon groupe vote
avec conviction cette proposition de loi
qui nous donne des responsabilités
nouvelles à l'égard des morts comme des
vivants
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à monsieur richard tuheiava
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons examiné
ensemble cet après midi une proposition
de loi déposée par le collègue du groupe
union centriste qui a pour objet
d'autoriser on voit bien saisi la
restitution de têtes maories à la france
en france à la nouvelle zélande
il s'agit vous en conviendrez
tout ça en dépit du très court texte de
loi qui nous est soumis d'un thème
législatif une importance cruciale pour
le patrimoine national en particulier
devant les enjeux nouveaux enjeux
internationaux qui se présente en tant
que polynésiens intimement liée à la
cause maori d'anti les costumes dans le
contre et insulaire de dire qu'ils sont
nos cousins culturel je suis
profondément sensibles au sujet qui nous
réunit cet après midi il est ici
question d'éthique de dignité humaine
post mortem de diversité culturelle et
de respect d'un système de croyances
propres au peuple maori de ce qu'on
appelle communément le pays du long
nuage blanc à ottawa plus connu sous
l'appellation nouvelle zélande
il est aussi question de sacralité
partagé par tous les peuples aussi un
lien dans certains fonds je voudrais
appel partie de la république française
ou alice et autonome la nouvelle
calédonie et la polynésie française dont
je suis le représentant aujourd'hui pour
ne citer que deux exemples le terme
marine que le terme autochtone du terme
maori qui désigne autochtone de la
polynésie française je suis également en
charge de la nomination d'un site
polynésien sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial qui représente pour les maoris
le dernier
lieu de repos des âmes de tous les
ancêtres marie séparément effectivement
du sort ou du lieu où la sépulture été
choisie en tant que parlementaire je ne
peux que m'inscrire dans cette dynamique
législative novatrice et ouverte vers
l'autre avec un grand a
dont les ti prend le dessus sur les
clivages politiques nationaux et
régionaux
al'annonce de l'examen en séance
publique de cette proposition de loi
je n'ai pu résister à l'impérieux
réflexe protocolaire le plan de la tâche
nos cousins marie d'intérêt afin de
veiller modestement à mon modeste niveau
à ce que l'objet de la loi soit toujours
conformes à leurs souhaits c'est le cas
j'imagine que mes collègues et l'union
centriste à l'origine de la proposition
de loi on était déjà persuadé
je n'ai pas non plus résisté à aller
prendre la température sur le terrain en
visitant avant-hier le musée d'histoire
naturelle de rouen et la réserve où se
trouve la tête maories momifiées en
présence des autorités municipales et de
la direction du musée afin de comprendre
les enjeux locaux nationaux et
internationaux de cette problématique
posée
il va aussi été donnée à cette occasion
deux en visite
madame la députée maire de rouen qui m'a
assuré de sa détermination de celles de
son conseil municipal dans lequel
siègent également notre collègue
sénatrice catherine morin desailly à
voir aboutir cette démarche de
restitution de la têtes maories
momifiées aux autorités néo zélandaises
je souhaiterais passage au passage
pendant saluer officiellement le courage
et l'audace de toute l'équipe municipale
de la ville de rouen qu'elles soient
antérieurs
depuis les élections municipales de 2008
dans la prise de la décision de faire
droit à la demande des autorités néo
zélandaises de provoquer le débat qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui en décidant
contra legem c'est-à-dire sciemment
contre l'état du droit positif français
qui classe encore les restes du corps
humain comme objet
deux collections des musées de france en
définitive de relancer le pavé dans la
mare ce courage méritait d'être salué
notre collègue catherine morin desailly
a rappelé très justement les deux normes
internationales qui trouve à s'appliquer
en france en la matière savoir la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones
la france a ratifié en 2007 mais aussi
le code de déontologie de l'icom par
solidarité envers nos cousins culturel
du pacifique
par conviction traditionnelle profonde
mais aussi par souci d'éthique
je vois très dense pour le principe de
la proposition de loi qui sera examiné
par la haute assemblée par le sénat et
pour poser quelques amendements modeste
que j'ai estimé nécessaire mais au-delà
de ce vote d'une proposition loi
nominative de circonstances relatives
aux têtes maories encore entreposées en
en france il s'agit de poser
publiquement la question plus générale
de l'état du droit positif français en
matière de restes du corps humain nous
ne pourrons plus au cas par cas souhaité
éternellement ce type de sollicitations
internationale au moyen de lois
nominative de circonstance son maître la
france andré elle difficulté face à la
prise de conscience croissante
quand les pays environnants des outils
internationaux que je viens de citer
c'est d'ailleurs ce vide juridique qui a
conduit le comité de pilotage de la
ville de rouen pour ne citer que cet
exemple a adopté la démarche de
restitution de la têtes maories
momifiées que le musée d'histoire
naturelle de joie conserver en réserve
depuis 1875 il nous faudra donc repensé
dans un avenir prochain notre
législation et réglementation inadaptée
à ce type de situation en tranchant
clairement ce débat jeudi qu culturel
émergents tout en instituant des
garanties légales innovante qui ne soit
plus de celle qui trahissent encore
quelques
en filigrane a passé colonial dans tout
le monde tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'il était peu glorieux je vous
remercie
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur louis duvernois
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je m'associe aux précédents
orateurs pour vous souhaitez également
la bienvenue au sénat mes chers
collègues le respect dû aux croyances
d'un peuple nous amène aujourd'hui à
examiner une proposition de loi
autorisant la restitution à la nouvelle
zélande des têtes maories détenues par
les musées français
les têtes humaines tatouées et momifiées
sont une tradition du peuple maori et
revêtent dans leur culture un caractère
sacré avant l'arrivée des européens
les chefs marc wii était à touih selon
des codes très précis à la fois sociaux
et religieux relevant de la tribu à
laquelle il appartenait
lorsque l'un d'entre nous est au combat
sa tête était conservée et exposé dans
un endroit consacré à sa mémoire
jusqu'au moment où l'on estimait que
l'âme du défunt était parti la tête
était alors inhumé près de son village
les européens entrés au contact de ces
populations au cours du xviiie siècle
furent fascinés par ces têtes orné et en
rapportèrent quelques-unes en europe la
demande des collectionneurs fut
tellement forte qu'un véritable commerce
s'instaura entre les maris et les
européens la raréfaction rapide des
têtes donna lieu à des supercheries
certains maori n'hésitèrent pas à
tatouer des esclaves puis à les exécuter
pour obtenir des têtes
la révélation publique de ces pratiques
suscitent à en angleterre un scandale le
tels que la reine victoria fit voter une
loi en 1831 interdisant le commerce des
têtes entre la nouvelle-zélande et
l'australie
le peuple maori n'a pas disparu il
représente aujourd'hui environ 600000
personnes depuis les années 60
le gouvernement néo-zélandais a adopté
une politique de soutien à la culture
maori doublé de mesures de restitution
des terres et d'indemnisation des tribus
souliers le gouvernement a également mis
en place un programme de rapatriement et
d'identification des têtes coupées en
vue de leur restitution aux tribus ces
restes humains recevront ainsi une
sépulture conforme aux rites et
traditions de leur communauté d'origine
répondant à cette démarche de nombreux
pays à nous restituer les têtes maories
qu'il détenait 329 restes humains ont
été restitués sur un total estimé à
environ 500 en france la ville de rouen
a été la première à restituer une tête
détenue par son museau
mais cette restitution a eu lieu alors
que le tribunal administratif en avait
décidé autrement
invoquant l'inaliénabilité des biens
constituant les collections des musées
de france
cette affaire révélant un certain vide
juridique
à l'évidence l'initiative de madame
morin desailly vient clore le débat
ouvert sur le sort des têtes maories sa
proposition de loi compte de nombreux
cosignataires donc je suis et je me
réjouis que notre ordre du jour est
permis d'inscrire sa discussion
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'appliquer un
principe reconnu par le droit
international
le respect de la dignité humaine et de
la culture d'un peuple comme l'a
souligné notre rapporteur la restitution
des têtes maories est un ges éthiques
cependant les opposants à la restitution
de restes humains font valoir que ces
restes peuvent présenter un intérêt
scientifique imposant leur mise à
disposition pour des études futures le
maintien des têtes maories au sein de
nos collections pourrait par ailleurs se
juge
si fier par leur valeur de témoignage
historique comme l'ont fait valoir
certains conservateurs de musée mais les
opposants à la restitution des têtes
maories crime surtout que l'existence
d'un précédent ouvre la voie à une fuite
des pièces des collections nationales
les demandes de restitution
si elle se multipliaient pourrait mettre
en péril l'intégrité des collections il
faut tenir compte de cet aspect pour
cette raison la proposition de loi se
garde de donner une réponse législative
général et définitive à la question de
la restitution des restes humains la
demande de restitution constitue un cas
particulier bien spécifiques
elle n'est pas automatisé mais seulement
autorisé pour le cas mauri on voit
comment le sujet est complexe et
nécessite une réflexion d'ensemble sur
la restitution des restes humains
réflexion qui doit être mené en premier
lieu par les responsables des musées
en effet si nous réglons aujourd'hui un
cas d'espèce il ne faudrait pas comme
l'a souligné notre rapporteur que le
parlement soit contraints de légiférer
prochainement sur des cas semblables
je tiens à saluer le travail de notre
rapporteur philippe richert qui
s'étaient déjà impliqués en 2002 dans le
débat législatif pour la restitution des
restes de la vénus hottentote
un amendement adopté par la commission
vient compléter la proposition de loi
afin de réactiver la procédure de
déclassement institué en 2002 par la loi
sur les musées de france
la composition et les missions de la
commission scientifique nationale sont
modifiées afin qu'elle devienne
véritablement opérationnel
cette commission aura notamment pour
vocation de définir une doctrine
générale en matière de déclassement et
de cession permettant d'éclairer les
propriétaires et gestionnaires de
collection dans leur décision
elle devra remettre dans le délai d'un
an un rapport sur ses orientations en
matière de déclassement
ces dispositions me semble utile car la
loi de 2002 permettant le déclassement
des biens culturels et donc leur
restitution n'a pas trouvé
d'applications depuis son adoption
il apparaît urgent d' aborder ce débat
est de poser aussi clairement que
possible des principes qui guideront les
démarches des professionnels de nos
musées bien évidemment le groupe ump
votera cette proposition de loi
ainsi amendé je vous remercie
il circulait réparant l'état madame
marie-christine blandin
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la proposition de loi qui nous est
proposée sur la restitution des têtes
des maoris repose sur un élan éthique
partagée qui honore la ville qui en a
pris l'initiative est l'auteur du texte
et qui invite à l'approbation ce débat
s'inscrit dans un double héritage
le texte de 2002 sur la restitution à
l'afrique du sud de la dépouille de
saartjie baartman un débat préalable
avait à la fois mis en avant
l'inaliénabilité des collections des
musées avec l'article 50 du code du
domaine de l'état et la loi bioéthique
de 1994 qui dispose que le corps humain
ne peut faire l'objet d'un droit
patrimonial
malgré ce dernier point malgré les
demandes de l'afrique du sud ni le
ministère ni les musées n'avait donné
suite et nous avons dû légiférer alors
dans cet hémicycle le ministre de la
recherche de l'époque les deux je le
cite que l'on rende justice cette femme
qui a été l'objet durant et après sa vie
comme africaine et comme femme de temps
de france possédant du colonialisme du
sexisme et du racisme qui ont longtemps
prévenu il n'est pas inutile de rappeler
ici le rapport à l'académie de médecine
présenté par cuvier concluant les races
à crâne déprimé comprimés sont condamnés
à une éternelle infériorité et que ce
n'est qu'en janvier 2008 que j'ai enfin
pu faire éradiquer avec le soutien de la
commission des affaires culturelles le
mot race d'un texte de loi sur
l'audiovisuel
le sénat se montrant en avance sur les
conceptions de l'autre chambre
nous avons échoué pour éradiquer le mot
race dans la constitution mais nous y
reviendrons
au cours du débat de 2002 le risque du
précédent d'alien habilité qui
menacerait les collections avait été
soulevée l'autre texte qu'il nous fait
héritage et la loi sur les musées
on y avait senti vaciller
l'inaliénabilité par l'installation dans
le paysage de la notion de déclassement
en même temps que l'arrivée inédite d'un
amendement de l'assemblée nationale
préconisant à délai de trente ans avant
classement
d'autres événements dans un contexte de
tensions du marché de rareté des
subventions publiques ont laissé se
développer la notion de rentabilité des
institutions culturelles au travers de
la vente de leur marque à
l'international et avec le prêt
d'oeuvres aux limites du leasing
promesse de vente après versement
régulier
c'est dans ce contexte qu'il faut
interpréter la légitimité de certaines
réticences qui nous à vie tous à la
vigilance sur l'inaliénabilité et c'est
dans ce contexte que notre commission
n'a pas souhaité étendre les
possibilités de déclassement de la
commission et nous en remercions le
rapporteur
mais pour ce qui est des têtes maories
comme de tous reste humain faisant sens
pour un peuple le revendique quant au
nom de ses marchés de sa culture et
particulièrement au nom du respect des
ancêtres
les saynètes en verre sont résolument
favorable à ce que notre pays et ses
musées rang avec dignité
ce que l'histoire l'emprise d'un peuple
sur un autre où les goûts douteux de
collectionneurs ont enlevés à leur pays
d'origine les moeurs de tatouage du
visage des chef maori le moko était pour
eux une fierté mais aussi une épreuve
les entailles au couteau
en hausse puis l'application de celui de
l'arbre à gomme ou de ce nid carbonisé
n'était pas une partie de plaisir
et il fallait tout le rite de la
cérémonie les champs les cataplasmes des
feuilles pour que le jeune homme y
résistent la souffrance était telle
qu'on nourrit c'est le jeune guerrier
avec un entonnoir en bois durant des
semaines les esclaves que l'on t'a toit
en simulacre de chef pour vendre leur
tête ne te que la souffrance sans les
honneurs les morts ils sont vivants
reconnu actifs en nouvelle zélande et
dans l'ensemble polynésiens il siège
dans les instances officielles le 20
avril 2009 ils ont accompagné à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
helen clark nommé administrateur du sud
par une cérémonie de chants et de danses
rituelles le poly helen clark a été
premier ministre de nouvelle zélande
depuis 1999 travailliste dans le cadre
de ses fonctions elle avait donné
priorité à l'accès au logement à la
protection de la biodiversité à la santé
publique à l'égalité des sexes et aux
liens entre les mains au riz et les
paquets hâte c'est à dire les européens
c'est dans cet esprit de liens et de
respect que nous sont demandés les têtes
maories et c'est pour nous un devoir
moral historique que de construire
rapidement les conditions de leur retour
c'est pourquoi nous soutiendrons ce
texte parce qu'il est resté dans son
épure éthique initial je vous remercie
chers collègues la discussion générale
est close nous passons la discussion du
texte élaboré par la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication à l'article 1er
nous sommes saisis de deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
est déposée par monsieur par notre
collecte usa il nous appartient de
résoudre présenter ces deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
une son président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je serais bref je
pense qu'on peut effectivement envisager
l'examen des amendements en fait dans la
globalité puisque en fait le deuxième
amendement n'est qu'un amendement que le
pli le texte en fait de la proposition
de loi mais également le texte de la
commission ne contenait aucune données
temporelles ni délai auquel la démarche
national de restitution des têtes
maories à la nouvelle zélande serait
assujetti faute de quoi la présente
proposition de loi ou tech la commission
plein manquait effectivement en de
visibilité pratique et donc de
crédibilité vis-à-vis de nous nous à vis
des autorités néo zélandaises notre part
l'absence de délai de restitution
concret ouvrirait la part belle à
d'éventuelles tentatives et passe de
mesures dilatoires soit par exemple la
condition d'inventaire préalable etc qui
pourrait vider la présente loi de sa
substance c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai pris la responsabilité
effectivement de déposer deux
amendements successifs
l'un qui est celui de proposer un délai
de restitution maximale de six mois à
contrer raconté pardon de la lentille en
vigueur de la loi et le deuxième
amendement
un délai plus élargie d'un d'une année
qui correspondrait en fait aux délais
qui est sollicité par la commission dont
pour le dépôt d'un rapport au parlement
s'agissant donc de la commission
nationale scientifiques sont définis
chers collègues avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
oui chers collègues je serai évidemment
tenté de répondre favorablement
parce que j'avais initialement
exactement la même volonté de limiter
moi je pensais un ou deux ans est en
réalité nous sommes allés voir
l'ambassadrice de nouvelle zélande à
paris nous allons discuter avec elle en
lui proposant les conclusions disons ben
voilà on va mettre que dans un an il
faut et c'est elle qui a demandé de ne
pas le mettre en disant que le respect
des procédures avec en particulier
l'accueil d'abord en france dans un
musée que peut-être un deuxième un
troisième avec l'accueil de l'ancêtre
avec les cérémonials qui doivent suivre
puis le rapatriement ça va peut-être
prendre plus de temps que nous n'avons
prévu
donc c'est elle qui nous a demandé de ne
pas mettre de date pour permettre à ce
que cela puisse se passer dans des
conditions qui soient à la fois sereine
et et en même temps respectueuse de la
façon d'en bas dont les tribus souhaite
réintégrer les ancêtres dans leur
mémoire et dans leur existence
alors pour éviter l'inconvénient que
vous avez signalé bien on a rajouté dans
l'article 1er le fait de bien rappeler
que c'est pour rendre ces têtes maories
à la nouvelle zélande
parce qu initialement c'est n'y était
pas on l'a marqué pour éviter que tel
musée le cas échéant ne déclasse mais
pour autant ne rentrent pas donc pour
bien le marquer que nous l'avons inscrit
dans la loi pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
discussion possible
la raison pour laquelle je vous
demanderais de bien vouloir retirer ses
deux abandons
si nous nous serions amenés je le
regretterai a donné un avis défavorable
puisque nous sommes on le voit bien
parfaitement convergent dans nos
analyses cercles de youtube
ils ont retiré ils sont lui retirer chez
retirer
donc je consulte sur l'article 1er qui
est favorable à l'article 1er qui et
pour qui et contre il n'y en a pas
unanimité article de nouveaux quais pour
pas d'opposition unanimité article 3 qui
est pour
unanimité
il est adopté article 4 qui et pour qui
est content
unanimité il est adapté nous avons
maintenant un dernier amendement
présenté par me tuer ya va consulter
concernant l'intitulé de la proposition
de loi c'est l'amendement numéro un
il présentait chers collègues s'il vous
plaît oui ce résident en fait l'objet du
présent amendement en fait à vous de
plus dû préciser l'identité de l'état
bénéficiaire de la restitution des têtes
maories stasio mazel ans dont l'intitulé
loin d'être superfétatoire en fait cette
précision est nécessaire et je pense que
la wii fit véritablement le périmètre
d'application de la présente proposition
de loi et j'espère que tout le monde
sera d'accord
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
quel est votre avis la commission a
donné un avis favorable
ram monsieur le ministre quel est votre
avis si je donne également un avis
favorable
je remercie qui est pour le moment
numéro 1 qui est contre unanimité
il est adopté avant de mettre voir
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
je crois que vous avez souhaité prendre
la parole monsieur le ministre après le
vote
pardon je vous prie de m'excuser
ministre madame morin desailly a demandé
la parole et je ne l'avais pas vu merci
monsieur le président quelques instants
avant le vote
je voulais dire que j'ai avait été
particulièrement sensible à ce débat aux
arguments avancés par les différents
sénateurs qui se sont exprimés avec leur
sensibilité particulière leurs
réflexions et leurs connaissances
également approfondir particulière est à
cet égard je remercie notre collègue de
polynésie notre collègue touya va qui
nous a apporté encore un autre un autre
regard
je voulais vous remercier aussi monsieur
le ministre de la démarche de
compréhension et sensibilité que vous
avez sur ce sujet et je voudrais
souligner à quel point notre rapporteur
a amendé très utilement ma proposition
de loi notamment spécifiant que non
seulement les têtes maories
si la loi est adoptée d'ici quelques
instants seront déclassées des
collections mais surtout qu'elles seront
restitués à la nouvelle zélande
et si notre collègue a accepté de
retirer son amendement concernant le
délai je voulais lui dire que nous
serons particulièrement attentifs à ce
que dès que la nouvelle zélande sera
prêt parce que ces cérémonies en effet
peuvent prendre un certain temps
et bien nous serons là nous coller qui
soutenons ce projet de loi pourrait être
particulièrement attentifs à ce que les
portes des réserves de nos musées ne se
referme pas mais souffre au contraire
tout grand pour accueillir les maoris
qui viendront chercher leur sens et
c'est important de le de le rappeler
parce que cette démarche elle n'a de
sens que si elle va jusqu'au bout tout
cas je vous remercie
je remercie chaque année je vais mettre
en voix l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi y at il d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
il n'y en a pas alors je mets aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
ceux qui sont favorables bien levé la
main s'il vous plaît avis contraire
abstention il n'y a pas unanimité
monsieur le ministre vous avez souhaité
prendre la parole
oui monsieur le président je vous
remercie de me redonner la parole je
voudrais d'abord remercier très
chaleureusement la sénateure la
sénatrice catherine morin desailly à qui
l'on doit l'initiative de cette
proposition de loi et qui doit se sentir
profondément récompensés à la fois
vis-à-vis de ses convictions et de leur
qualité vis-à-vis de l'engagement moral
ce qu'elle avait pris dans son for
intérieur à l'égard de la communauté
maori et vis-à-vis de son initiative qui
a suscité donc l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi
je remercie évidemment bien sûr le
sénateur philippe richert pour la
qualité de son travail de rapporteur et
j'irai retrouver d'ailleurs
l'implication profonde qu'il ressent
pour ce genre de problème je voulais
simplement faire deux observations l'une
grave et l'autre secondaire celle qui
est grave c'est qu'on ne construit pas
une culture sur un trafic c'est qu'on ne
construit pas une culture sur un crime
et je pense notamment aux esclaves qui
se sont retrouvés pris au piège d
horribles commerce exercées par des
européens
peut-être même avec des complicités
locales et en revanche on construit une
culture sur le respect et sur les
changes semble évident le rappeler mais
peut-être qu'il faut le faire encore
on construit une culture sur une
véritable pratique de la mémoire et on
construit une culture sur le respect
d'un certain nombre de procédures et de
loi je vous sens ému madame morin
desailly et nous partageons votre
émotion et la deuxième observation
technos peyras une observation beaucoup
plus frivole dans le cadre des débats
d'aujourd'hui c'est que le mot
inaliénabilité est décidément difficile
à prononcer bien je vous remercie
monsieur nuit vous venez de suivre
l'adoption par les sénateurs de la
proposition de loi qui autorise la
restitution des têtes maories à la
nouvelle zélande
prochain rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires cet après midi pour un
débat sur les collectivités
territoriales c'est à partir de 16h30 à
suivre sur public sénat